mesdames et messieurs bonsoir
une fois encore l'iran a connu une
journée d'émeutes sanglantes 41 morts ce
samedi à machad la ville sainte
l'armée a tiré sur les manifestants de
téhéran cela continue mais on a
l'impression cette fois que l'on
approche d'un certain dénouement car
tous ces événements sont doublés d'une
confusion politique totale on avait
annoncé la nuit dernière le départ du
shah il a fait savoir aujourd'hui qu'il
n'avait pas l'intention de quitter le
pays
en revanche sa mère et plusieurs
personnes de la famille royale sont
arrivés aujourd'hui aux états unis
d'autre part un opposant modéré monsieur
chapour bakhtiar tente toujours de
former un gouvernement civil
à l'initiative du souverain mais
monsieur bakhtiar vient d'être ce soir
exclu de son parti
il se retrouve donc seul à l'unanimité
que le front national a décidé ce soir
d'exclure de ses rangs monsieur bakhtiar
qui a accepté l'offre du chat de tenter
de former un gouvernement civil
c'est peut-être la dernière planche de
salut du régime qui s'écroule pourtant
monsieur bakhtiar vient de préciser il
ya quelques minutes à peine qu'il
continuerait sa mission toutefois pour
certains cette tentative pour être en
fait d'ici muller une manoeuvre du chat
pour prouver au monde et surtout aux
américains qu'une solution politique est
impossible et que seul son action peut
rétablir la situation
le palais impérial réaffirme ce soir que
le chat n'a nullement l'intention de
quitter le pays aujourd'hui encore donc
l'armée à réprimer les manifestations
avec violence 41 morts dans la ville
sainte de machhad et à téhéran sans
interruption des tirs de mitrailleuses
ont balayé les principales artères où
des groupes de jeunes criaient à mort le
chat le week-end pourrait bien amener un
dénouement à la crise un signe les
américains commencent à préparer
l'évacuation de leurs ressortissants et
on voit dans les parages croiser un
porte-avions de la 7e flotte
justin minutes ces événements du terrain
la présence du comté nations unies
également que les états unis donnent
déjà des alliés comme la radio j le
pétrole pour le président carter
d'économie d'énergie
je préfère les etats-unis sont prêts à
l'internet la rumeur n'en est rien pour
l'instant
la rumeur a été alimentée avec la rivale
au sein de la merde et désire voir avec
sa cuisse pourrait de la même réserve la
mer d'huile a été scellé la télé rappelé
qu'au satellite et nous permet encore
que l'ayatollah khomeini pourrait rester
peut rester en france pour une durée
indéterminée c'est la réponse des
autorités à sa demande de progrès la
prolongation de séjour dans notre pays
proche orient la paix toujours en
attente et le président sadate vient de
préciser que l'egypte ne signerait pas
avec israël sans qu'un lien soit établi
entre le règlement dans le sinaï et les
règlements futur en cisjordanie et à
gaza le président giscard d'estaing et
l'europe le chef de l'état dans une
interview au journal allemand der
spiegel souligne que l'europe ne devrait
pas engager des discussions sans fin sur
les institutions mais plutôt s'attaquer
avec énergie aux problèmes qui
préoccupent les hommes
monsieur giscard d'estaing indique en
outre que la manière dont le parlement a
pris position récemment sur le budget de
la communauté était juridiquement et
politiquement inacceptable
le président de la république a séjourné
à libreville au gabon
aujourd'hui il rentre dans la nuit à
paris demain il présentera ses voeux aux
france jean paul ii a nommé son
successeur à cracovie c'est le recteur
du grand séminaire de la vie
monseigneur machart ski qui devient
archevêque de cracovie
il est âgé de 51 ans et c'est un proche
collaborateur de karol wojtyla en france
tout un département est mobilisée pour
retrouver un homme qui s'attaque à des
jeunes femmes
ce département c'est l'oise ou des
battues ont été organisées toute la nuit
le maniaque de l'oise a fait une
nouvelle victime une jeune fille de 19
ans qui l'a grièvement blessé cette fois
lankais de la police va peut être avancé
car un témoin a vu ce maniaque toute la
nuit dans l'oise des barrages ont été
mis en place par la gendarmerie pour
tenter de retrouver l'agresseur d'une
jeune élève infirmière de 19 ans andré
poiré c'est hier vers 11 heures que la
jeune fille est prise en auto-stop
quelques minutes après la voiture
s'arrête en pleine campagne on retrouve
un peu plus tard la jeune élève
infirmière atteintes de quatre balles et
grièvement blessé sur le bord de la
route avant de tomber dans le coma elle
pourra donner un signalement de son
agresseur 25 ans environ
cheveux blonds portant moustache et
lunettes pour les policiers il ne fait
pas de doute que cet homme est le même
qui a au cours des sept derniers mois
assassiné dans la région une étudiante
de 19 ans blessé deux autres jeunes
femmes aient piégé à l'explosif trois
véhicules volés utilisés pour ces
agressions ce n'est que de justesse
cette fois ci que le meurtrier a pu
s'échapper
il a même été vu par plusieurs témoins
ça s'est passé et on a vu passer une
voiture à très grande vitesse
lui devant nous elle était de quelle
couleur cette voiture vers faire et
c'était quoi comme marque 64 il aller
très très vite très vite fait et c'est
même étonnant qu'il ait pu passer ce
virage c'est juste après sinon il
s'arrêter là et comment comment
savez-vous que c'était lui
d'après as peut-être trop quatre minutes
après gendarmes qui passait derrière
bon après avoir raté son virage
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait exactement elle a
été vers le lieu-dit la bascule c'est
près de l'oise et
disons environ 3 4 minutes après c'était
les gendarmes chu et apparemment ils ont
été bloqués à barrière tissu dessus peu
près 100 m 2 loué et la voiture vous
l'avez vu elle a été retrouvé au bas de
son maître du lieu dit la bascule en
direction de verberie et apparemment ne
s'était enlisé la wii bien visé est bien
dû continuer pied dans 1978 a encore 27
heures et 52 minutes à vivre
puis on passera aux chiffres suivants
alors nous avons juste le temps de jeter
une dernière fois un coup d'oeil sur les
événements qui ont animé le monde cette
année événement particulièrement riche
dans tous les domaines et donc non nous
avons sélectionné les plus significatifs
commençons par l'étranger sur la carte
du monde trois régions se sont mis à
clignoter annonçant une surprise
une déception une tragédie
la surprise a été de taille c'est
l'ouverture de la chine au monde
extérieur et dans cette partie un homme
a joué un rôle déterminant ça comme
c'est un camping que l'on voit ici reçu
à tokyo à l'occasion du traité sino
japonais c'est lui en effet calé
récidiver il ya tout juste quinze jours
en permettant la normalisation des
relations avec les états unis
un événement qui bouleverse toutes les
données de la politique en asie mais
aussi dans le monde
premier pays visé l'union soviétique qui
veut voir dans cette normalisation une
espèce de sainte alliance chine etats
unis dirigée contre elle
première conséquence un développement
sans précédent dans l'industrie chinoise
qui avec le concours de la technologie
japonaise américaine devrait rapidement
atteindre des sommets
c'est le voeu de taxi au ping qui veut
faire de la chine un pays puissant et
prospère
première victime enfin mao tsé toung
dont la politique est de plus en plus
critiqué à tel point que la chine tout
entière est en proie aujourd'hui à une
démobilisation qui n'ose pas encore dire
son nom
la déception elle vient bien évidemment
du proche-orient déception d'autant plus
grande que le 17 septembre dernier
tout paraissait possible
compris la paix avec ces fameux accords
de camp david jimmy carter avait mis
tout son poids dans la balance
anouar el sadate et menahem begin avait
suivi cela n'a pas suffi et tout cela à
cause d'une petite bande de territoire
appelé cisjordanie depuis la guerre des
six jours
les israéliens l'occupent et sont prêts
sous certaines conditions à s'en retirer
que ces conditions soient précisées dans
le texte de nos accords bilatéraux
disent les égyptiens
pas question répond les israéliens s'ils
n'y ont d'abord la paix ensuite nous
discuterons de la cisjordanie
le processus est bloqué l'année qui
vient permettra peut-être de trouver un
compromis à ce qui serait le plus grand
événement au proche orient depuis 30 ans
la fin de l'état de guerre entre
l'egypte et israël
la tragédie enfin c'est celle d'un homme
le chat qui ne se résout pas à quitter
le pouvoir celle d'un peuple aussi qui
depuis six mois n'en finit pas de
compter ses morts
car c'est un soulèvement sans précédent
auquel on assiste aujourd'hui en iran un
soulèvement que n'avait même pas prévu
les services secrets américains c'est
une révolte une révolution disent même
les iraniens contre la répression contre
la corruption contre le rêve d'un homme
qui à force d'occidentalisation vous
l'été personnaliser son peuple et dans
ce combat c'est tout naturellement la
religion chiite qui à les canaliser la
contestation
et pour cause le chat depuis 40 ans a
décimé toutes les formes d'opposition
autour de lui la seule existante
aujourd'hui en iran et en sel des
ayatollahs
le plus célèbre d'entre eux khomeiny est
aujourd'hui en france
il a engagé une lutte à mort avec le
shah d'iran
il a réussi à désorganiser totalement le
pays
reste à savoir si la solution de
remplacement qu'il propose sera
bénéfique pour le peuple iranien pour
tout le peuple iranien
la pierre d'angle de cette année 78 ce
sont les problèmes économiques et
sociaux
les deux mots les plus employés ont été
certainement chômage et inflation
avec au bout un ciel gris du point de
vue de l'économie l'année 78 aurait été
une année et grises marqué par les
difficultés du pays à se maintenir dans
un contexte mondial de plus en plus dur
dur par l'énergie toujours cher dur par
la concurrence des produits étrangers
cette concurrence des pays à bas
salaires d'extrême orient notamment
appris dans certains secteurs la lure
d'une guerre économique où les forces de
chacun n'était même pas clairement
définie à cause des variations
incontrôlée des monnaies et surtout du
dollar c'est donc dans un environnement
mondial fluctuant contradictoires mais
presque toujours hostile qu'il faut
examiner le tableau de bord de
l'économie française en 78
le voici les prix 1,10 fondamental pour
mesurer l'inflation les prix auront
augmenté de 10%
probablement un peu moins quand on sait
que l'allemagne est notre principal
partenaire tourne autour de 3%
on voit ce qui a séparé la france d'une
inflation suffisamment maîtriser pour
parler haut et fort sur le marché
international les trois derniers mois de
l'année traduisent toutefois un réel
progrès dont on espère beau en provient
aussi le commerce extérieur qui est
devenu bénéficiaire est la fermeté du
franc surtout face au dollar on ne
consolidera ses deux points positifs
encore une fois que si l'inflation
ralentit encore
dernier est gravissime signal allumé sur
notre tableau de bord celui de l'emploi
années grises de l'économie ni 78 aura
été une année noire pour tous ceux qui
ont perdu leur travail
le nombre des chômeurs s'est accru
régulièrement pendant toute l'année pour
dépasser un million d'euros en novembre
pourquoi là aussi on retrouve l'énergie
chère et la concurrence étrangère qui
provoque des faillites
on trouve aussi une productivité parfois
mauvaise parfois des structures dépasser
la coïncidence de tout cela voici les
difficultés de manufrance le textile
avec la chute de l'empiré moussac
voilà les chantiers navals et le groupe
terrain à marseille
et puis surtout 78 aura vu un événement
inouï l'effondrement d'un secteur tout
entier orgueil d industrie de naguère la
sidérurgie s'est trouvé à l'automne en
cessation de paiement pur et simple et
tardivement ramassées dans sa frappe
dans les banques créancières et surtout
par l'état la ruine et le ravalement
actuellement en cours de la sidérurgie
française pour en coûter des dizaines de
milliers d'emplois dans son énormité ce
drame social illustre parfaitement la
mutation économique imposée à la france
par la pression mondiale et illustre
aussi les efforts du gouvernement pour
opérer h cette mutation les mains libres
depuis la victoire politique de la
majorité en mars le gouvernement raymond
barre à consacrer 78 à une politique de
redressement fondé sur le redéploiement
industriel et la fermeté du franc
méthode attirer l'argent plutôt vers les
entreprises que vers les ménages
conséquence pas de relance ni de
prospérité immédiate par la consommation
mais plus tard par l'assainissement
économique et les exportations
la bourse a salué ce choix en montant
des 50 % en douze mois
mais si cette politique réussie ce sera
sur plusieurs années
à l'échelle de la seule année 78 malgré
certains efforts pour limiter les dégâts
comme le pacte national pour l'emploi
ces choix ont pesé sur le chômage et sur
beaucoup de pouvoir d'achat
en conclusion 78 aura été l'année de
l'austérité dans l'espoir d'un
redressement durable 79 sera l'année
d'un début de réponse 80 sans doute sera
celle des verdicts
en politique le principal fait s'est
déroulé au début de l'année les
élections dieu sait si elles ont suscité
des commentaires des discours des
polémiques pendant des mois et des mois
et puis le 12 mars 1978 les français
sont allés voter ensuite bien plus tard
on a parlé de décrispation sur le perron
de l'elysée
ce soir là les français retiennent leur
souffle dans leur énorme majorité ils
ont conscience que ce qui va être dit
dans quelques secondes peut
éventuellement modifier leur style de
vie et influencer leur avenir majorité
sortante 47% opposition 50,5 divers 2%
nouvelles estime résultats définitifs de
ce premier tour rouge 48% majorité 46
n'est qu'un premier tour mais les états
majors politiques savent que la gauche
aura du mal à gagner ces élections
le lendemain les trois parties d'union
en terre tant bien que mal l'âge de la
discorde qui les ruinent depuis six mois
le parti socialiste le parti communiste
et le mouvement des radicaux de gauche
décide le désistement réciproque de tous
les candidats pour les candidats de
gauche arrivés en tête au premier tour
c'est sourire un peu forcé disparaissent
tout à fait le soir du 19 mars la
majorité reste la majorité
elle obtient 285 députés nos positions
200 et comme c'était prévisible
l'union de la gauche va éclater enfin le
20 mars
valéry giscard d'estaing commentent les
élections il relance la décrispation
qu'il est temps d'en venir à ce que
j'appellerais une cohabitation
régionales
cette fois il est entendu pendant trois
jours tous les leaders politiques et
syndicaux vont à l'elysée s'entretenir
avec lui la décrispation tournera court
avec les communistes
elle se maintiendra avec les socialistes
et ira jusqu'à diviser les radicaux de
gauche
mais toutes toutes les formations
politiques sont bouleversés par les
résultats de mars au parti socialiste à
rivalité sourde entre michel rocard est
françois mitterrand éclate à la
convention du 25 novembre
elle prend appui sur une divergence
d'analysé quant aux raisons de la
défaite
enfin les communistes et aussi en caisse
la marée de l'espoir déçu la direction
de georges marchais contester la fronde
des intellectuels très vite elles
s'étalent au grand jour d'hui saint
etienne que nous allons voir quelques
instants comment voulez vous que nous ne
soyons pas d'accord avec des gens qui
sont d'accord avec nous ne sommes
toujours pas le débat continue toujours
au parti communiste mais le souvenir des
élections de mars va peu à peu
s'estomper et bientôt un autre débat
commence l'europe les questions
européennes vont en fin d'année diviser
la majorité
pourtant le 21 novembre le chef de
l'état avait bien précisé au cours d'une
conférence de presse que l'europe à
laquelle ils penseraient confédéral à
l'assemblée le rpr de monsieur chirac
malgré la trêve qu'il a proposé au
gouvernement de monsieur par vote avec
les communistes au début du mois de
décembre contre la tva européenne
il reviendra sur son vote le rpr lorsque
monsieur chirac lance le 8 décembre son
appel de cochin aussi d'autres analysés
dans les couloirs de l'assemblée
mais cette tempête parlementaire était à
peine apaisée que jacques chirac cette
fois déclaré la guerre dans un message
de trois pages qui devait être lue
devant le conseil politique qui
s'adressait en fait aux militants et
bien là il le fait avec une violence
d'expression encore jamais atteinte il
dit un non catégorique à l'europe du
président de la république le 11
décembre une nouvelle faille s'ouvre
dans la majorité il s'agit de savoir
s'il faut accepter l'argent européen
celui des communautés pour alimenter la
campagne pour l'élection du parlement
européen
une fois encore les communistes des
chiraquiens sont d'accord et votent
ensemble contre le texte
le rpr donne la parole à son combattant
anti européen
michel d'hooghe considérables ont été
détournées de leur objet 12 milliards de
centimes
il n'appartient en aucune façon aux
organes de la communauté de faire de la
propagande et il n'appartient en
façon un assemblée des communautés
européennes de subventionner de campagne
électorale pour la deuxième fois en
quelques jours le pc et le rpr ce sont
donc alliés
on peut dire contre l'udf et le parti
social et monsieur marché au cours d'un
meeting rappelle les slogans anti
européen du pc tous les patriotes
nous disons non et résolument non à
l'europe à l'intégration européenne et
atlantique
nous disons non à leur emballement
est ce la rupture dans la majorité à
propos de l'europe
l'udf par la voix de monsieur chinaud ne
le pense pas il y à des discordances
mais ce vrai rhdp a pris combattre le
chef de l'état sont peu nombreux aux
yeux de monsieur chine
pour le plan européen je suis tenté de
dire qu'il y a des gens qui mènent des
combats derrière regard sur l'europe ce
n'est pas le premier ce n'est pas le
dernier
mais finalement je sais que l'opinion en
france dans sa majorité souhaitent que
la construction européenne se développe
on en est là l'élément nouveau est
important est celui ci dès lundi
prochain c'est la france avec monsieur
jean françois-poncet ministre des
affaires étrangères qui présidera le
conseil des ministres de la communauté
l'institution la plus importante du
marché comme toujours plus aux 10es
l'aviatrice maryse bastié toujours plus
c'est vrai et c'est finalement rassurant
l'homme la science et la technique ont
ensemble connu leur record leur aventure
n'aurait la publication du rapport
n'aura minc sur l'informatisation de la
société la france et sa classe politique
découvre vraiment l'ordinateur et ses
problèmes
un nouveau mot et même inventé issu du
mariage de cet ordinateur avec les
télécommunications c'est la télématique
parallèlement le progrès technique
permet de construire de tout petit
ordinateur baptisé micro qui nous
promettons vont envahir notre vie
quotidienne
on les retrouvera dans notre salle à
manger dans notre salon voir notre
cuisine mais un peu trop cher pour des
bourses moyennes ils vont se faire
attendre un an ou deux si toutefois on
leur trouve une application réelle pour
le grand public
la science permet aussi des exploits
humains trois américains abruzzo
anderson et newman ont réussi la
traversée de l'atlantique en ballon
libre c'est à dire simplement poussé par
les vents pour venir des états unis en
france ils ont mis cent trente sept
heures et six minutes c'était la 17e
tentative et les aérostiers aurait
souhaité pouvoir se poser au bourget
lindbergh en 1927 regardez bien ces deux
hommes qui arrivent à moscou ils
viennent de passer 140 jours dans
l'espace pendant près de cinq mois ils
sont restés enfermés dans une cabine
spatiale privée de sensation de poids
d'orientation et de goût pourtant ils
sont en pleine forme grâce aux exercices
musicaux mis au point en urss
c'est d'exploit ouvre selon les
responsables de l'espace soviétique les
vols humains vers les planètes voisines
de la terre
comme tous les ans la terre a bougé un
peu partout et cette année un phénomène
exceptionnel s'est produit à 100 km à
l'est de djibouti pour la première fois
on a pu étudier avec précision une
fissure de la croûte terrestre pour la
première fois les scientifiques ont pu
constater sur terre un événement qui se
passe en principe au fond des océans la
dérive des continents
ce qu'il ya de remarquable c'est que
cette fissure avait été prévu par aranda
ziem il ya environ cinq ans et que
l'institut géographique national avait
installé des balises pour mesurer
l'écartement des fissures la lave que
l'on voit s'échapper sert en quelque
sorte à boucher le vide provoqué par la
faille
en dehors d'une meilleure connaissance
de la terre ce phénomène exceptionnel
permettra peut-être de mieux comprendre
l'évolution de notre planète et peut
être un jour de prévoir les catastrophes
3 mai 1978 première journée
internationale consacrée à l'énergie
solaire c'est aux etats-unis que ce
sunday et le plus fêté à travers tout le
pays des expositions solaires voisinent
avec les chants et les danses au lever
du soleil
en france nous allons aussi connaître un
jour du soleil en 79
ce sera le 23 juin solstice d'été et
nuit d'un saint jean patronné par
antenne de cette journée du soleil se
déroulera dans toute la france pour bien
montrer que 79
c'est l'an 1 du solaire chez nous
oh
oui les problèmes de société les drames
n'ont peut-être pas été plus nombreux
que les autres années mais ils ont été
pour certains inexplicable on a souvent
pensé en les vivant comment ces choses
ont-elles pu se produire
marée noire en bretagne événement
national et mondial le plus important de
l'année soixante dix huit pour les
français
drame écologique provoquée par le
naufrage de l'amoco cadiz au premier
rang des souvenirs 230 mille tonnes de
pétrole dans la mer
le goémon détruits sur plusieurs
centaines de kilomètres de côtes la
pêche des crustacés ralenti pendant plus
de deux mois
l'ostréiculture ravagé vingt mille
oiseaux tués une saison touristique
médiocre 400 millions de francs lourd
dépensés pour dépolluer le littoral et
la grande leçon de cette peste noire qui
endeuillent l océan
au seuil du printemps 78 carences du
plan polmar absence d'un remorqueur
assez puissant dans les eaux
territoriales pour tirer le géant blessé
scandale des pavillons de complaisance
de la qualification des équipages et
peur de l'avenir de vendeuse chip 30000
navires empruntent chaque jour le rail à
l'ouest d'ouessant dont plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de pétroliers qui
transporte au total plus de 450 millions
de tonnes de carburant
le 11 juillet à 15 heures un mi-chemin
entre valence et barcelone
un camion coup bourré de propylène
quitte la route bordant des campings
explose 150 vacanciers terrisse
carbonisés c'était comme du napalm
racontent les témoins tout brûler tous
font des los alpha caisse relancera le
grand débat sur le transport des
matières dangereuses
aucun pays diront les experts n'est à
l'abri d'une telle catastrophe
une simple soudure défectueuse de la
citerne transportant le gaz liquéfié est
à l'origine de ce drame en espagne
l'année 78 vu se multiplier en france
les gestes d'autodéfense une véritable
psychose qui atteint aussi bien les
villes que les campagnes peur viscérale
défaillance de la police faiblesse de la
justice
les français sam et fut il y à des
bavures graves
le ministre de l'intérieur son ennemi
même inquiété en conseil des ministres
le procès n'est pas simple car l'auto
défense revêt plusieurs visas certains
forcené de la gâchette ont été traduits
en justice et condamner la décision a
divisé la france sur ce problème
les voleurs devenu victime l'été dans
plusieurs cas que des adolescents la
trouille du loubard à transformer dans
dead citoyen meurtrier années soixante
dix huit entre la peur et la raison les
6 35 7 65 et autres calibres sont
entrées dans les maisons
la promesse du ministre de l'intérieur
d' améliorer la sécurité des français d
en fera peut-être l'année prochaine
ressorti
samedi de novembre dans une colonie
agricole au coeur de la forêt guyanaise
923 ressortissants américains adeptes de
la secte du temple du peuple viennent de
se suicider sous la houlette d'un dément
jim jones
avant ce suicide collectif les disciples
du révérend ont assassiné un
représentant démocrate de californie
venu enquêter sur leur activité
trois journalistes d'une chaîne
américaine de télévision et un
photographe
après charles manson et ses messages
écrits dans le sang la californie où les
sectes abonde via une nouvelle fois de
rencontrer le diable en france on se dit
que décidément le nouveau monde est fou
l'amérique est malade de ses c'est des
images idylliques du rêve américain dans
les années 50 au cauchemar du temple du
peuple
il s'est écoulé un quart de siècle
chacun en voyant ces images s'est posé
cette question pourquoi des américains
en sont ils arrivés aujourd'hui la
poussée par la folie d'un homme nommé
jim jones
voilà mais ce n'est pas tout évidemment
il faudrait parler de bien d'autres
événements tristes et plus gaie qui ont
couvert les colonnes de nos journaux
je ne retiendrai que deux pour conclure
d'abord l'élection d'un pape polonais le
16 octobre 1978 après deux deuils
successifs au vatican un pape venu de
l'étranger c'était déjà beaucoup mais du
monde communiste
cela paraît incroyable beaucoup y ont vu
un témoignage la vitalité de l'église
alors qu'elle traverse des moments
difficiles
et puis il y eut louise le premier bébé
éprouvette
elle est née en angleterre dans la nuit
du 25 au 26 juillet victoires de la
médecine je dirais plutôt un pied-de-nez
à l'avenir et à l'espérance que le
sourire de louise
le comédia où la comédienne de l'année
il y en a beaucoup
alors nous avons fait un choix c'est
pierre richard parce que c'est l'acteur
dit-on le plus heureux de france
oui parce qu'il a eu deux millions et
demi de spectateurs qui ont versé pour
aller le voir 30 millions 133 1727
chiffres arrêtés le 5 décembre et que
mon dieu ça n'est pas rien mais quand
même quand on se balade dans la rue
comme ça avec beaucoup de gens qui vous
admirent
on ne se prend pas obligé de tomber tous
les dix mètres sur une peau de banane
est ce qu on ne se croit pas obligé de
prendre l'air gai tout le temps même
quand on n'a pas envie oui oh certes
vous savez l'opinion des gens qu'ont les
gens sur les artistes est très variable
je pense un peu d'amis qui du sud-ouest
qui est artistes et comédiens qui
s'appelle l'axé qui réagit ont été
interpellés dans un café par par un
buveur qui lui dit alors monsieur
l'accès toujours artistes et cochons oui
un petit peu ce qu'on a ce qu'on pense
de nous déjà d'une part et d'autre part
en ce qui concerne les comics ont pensé
vctv effectivement que ils ont toujours
du chaudron l'a dit ou à raconter mais
ce sont souvent les gens qui
m'interpelle qui me font rire par
exemple vraiment une interpellation qui
me fait le plus rire dans un café c'est
un type qui m'a donné une grande claque
dans le dos en disant excusez moi
monsieur mais j'ai fait un pari avec ma
femme on pour je suis souvent l'objet de
paris lyon paris chinoise tout de suite
avoué mon âge ou embrasser une dame qui
a parié qu'elle réussirait à lembras les
choses comme ça quand je suis en forme
ça vaille au lit je fais un pari je
parle et vous et yves robert ou plutôt
ma femme a parié vous étiez yves robert
alors j'ai dit non je ne suis pas yves
robert alors il appelle sa fin dans la
caf et déjà clé